WON'T.
JESSE: FAKE NEWS AND FAST FOOD.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF TONIGHT'S
JESSE WATTERS WORDS.
THE CONE OF THE COVERAGE, 90%
NEGATIVE AND 10% POSITIVE.
CLEMSON WON THE CHAMPIONSHIP AND
WAS INVITED TO THE WHITE HOUSE
AS IS CUSTOMARY.
BECAUSE OF THE SHUTDOWN THERE
WEREN'T ANY CHEFS TO CATER IT.
SO THE PRESIDENT FIGURED IT OUT.
>> DO WE GIVE YOU A QUICK SALAD
ALONG WITH THE FIRST LADY AND
THE SECOND LADY.
AND I SAID YOU GUYS AREN'T INTO
SALADS.
DO I SEND OUT FOR 1,000
HAMBURGERS.
WE HAVE BIG MACS, QUARTER
POUNDERS WITH CHEESE, WE HAVE
EVERYTHING THAT YOU LIKE AND I
LIKE.
JESSE: THE PLAYERS LOVED THAT.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THEIR SOCIAL
MEDIA PAGE.
THEY WENT BACK FOR SECONDS.
>> NORMALLY I WOULD HAVE A SALAD
FOR DINNER ON MONDAY.
BUT THEY TOLD ME THEY ONLY EAT
FAST FOOD.
>> HE'S PAYING THE CHECK SO THEY
HAD TO GET THE CHEAPEST FOOD YOU
COULD FIND.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE YOU ARE
PROJECTING YOUR FAVORITE FOODS
ON TO THEM.
>> WE'LL EAT ALL YOUR FAVORITE
FOODS FAN WATCH THEIR FAVORITE
MOVIE, THE 2016 ELECTION
RESULTS.
JESSE: ONE HOST ON ESPN SAID
SERVING FAST FOOD TO FOOTBALL
PLAYERS IS RACIST.
>> WHEN I SAW HIM GIVING THE
FOOTBALL MAYORS PREDOMINANTLY
PLAQUE FAST FOOD, MY THOUGHT
WENT TO A DIFFERENT PLACE.
JESSE: PRESIDENT OBAMA LIKED
FAST FOOD AND PIES AND ICE
CREAM.
HERE IS BARACK OBAMA MAKING A
RUN TO FIVE GUYS TO FEED THE
WHITE HOUSE STAFF.
>> TWO BURGERS FOR BREAKFAST.
WE ARE GOING TO GET BURGERS AND
I CAN BRING THEM BACK FOR YOU.
DO YOU WANT FRIES?
>> SURE.
>> ONE CHEESE BIGGER AND FRIES
FOR ME.
LETTUCE, KETCHUP AND PICKLES.
LOOK HOW THE MEDIA COVERED
OBAMA.
"THE WASHINGTON POST," PRESIDENT
OBAMA, AND CHEESE BURGERS A LOVE
STORY.
THE DOUBLE STANDARDS DON'T STOP
THERE.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM
IOWA, STEVE KING, MADE A
SHOCKING COMMENT SAYING HE
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE TERM
WHITE SUPREMACIST IS OFFENSIVE.
BUT MSNBC SPUN HIS COMMENTS THIS
WAY.
>> THIS DOES NOT HAVE A PARALLEL
ON THE LEFT.
IT DOESN'T.
THERE ISN'T A STRAIN OF RACISM
ON THE LEFT.
JESSE: THERE IS NOT?
THE TRUTH IS BOTH PARTIES HAVE
PROBLEMS ON THEIR FRINGES.
THE LEFT HAS AN ANTI-SEMITISM
PROBLEM.
>> THE JEWS DON'T LIKE FARRAKHAN
SO THEY CALL ME HITLER.
WELL THAT'S A GOOD NAME.
HITLER WAS A VERY GREAT MAN.
THEY CALL ME AN ANTI-SEMITE.
STOP IT.
I AM ANTI-TERMITE.
AND FARRAKHAN HAS PULLED THE
COVER OFF OF THAT SATANIC JEW.
JESSE: AND HERE IS FARRAKHAN
POSING WITH BARACK OBAMA.
THIS IS A PICTURE THE MEDIA
SUPPRESSED BEFORE HIS ELECTION.
HERE IS MAXINE WATERS HUGGING
THE NATION OF ISLAM LEADER.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE HAVE TO STOP DEMONIZING
PEOPLE AND REALIZE THE BIGGEST
TERROR THREAT IS WHITE MEN, MOST
OF OF THEM RADICALIZED UP TO THE
RIGHT AND WE HAVE TO START DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
JESSE: WHITE MEN ARE THE BIGGEST
THREAT TO AMERICA.
THEN THERE IS THE LANGUAGE.
>> I HAVE GOT TO GET TO NEBRASKA
MORE.
>> WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
WORK IN THE FIELDS WITH US.
>> WORK IN THE FIELDS?
I AM A HOUSE [BLEEP].
YOU ARE A WHITE [BLEEP]
>> I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF WHITE
[BLEEP] IN MY TIME IF YOU WANT
TO USE THAT WORD.
>> [BLEEP] WHITE MAN.